es gibt keine runde in deutschland die
in der korona krise mehr macht hat und
die trotzdem so viele fragen aufwirft
wir schränken die freizeitgestaltung
erheblich allen ich kenne auch keine
runde in der deutschen politik die uns
journalisten gegenüber geschwätziger ist
obwohl sie eigentlich vertraulich takt
im prinzip könnte man zu diesen ganzen
veranstaltungen wird die medien zu
schalten
und es gibt auch kein gremium wurden
nachmittag die eine teilnehmerin
verkündet die schulen bleiben
geschlossen und fast zeitgleich ein
anderer was ganz anderes sagt das ist
nun zeitgleich so lief das war wirklich
ungünstig es geht natürlich um die
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz mit angela
merkel unsere bundesländer corona
entscheider und sozusagen das kriegs
kabinett dieser corona pandemie
was passiert da eigentlich ist das alles
nur gelaber gequatsche bei merkels
coroner runde
wir schauen heute mal hinter die
kulissen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ich bin florian neumann hauptstadt
korrespondent für das zdf in berlin und
seit corona ist diese
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz diese mpk
für uns der mit abstand wichtigste
termin
wie oft habe ich in dieser krise schon
auf diese blaue wand im kanzleramt
gstaad und gewartet und dann dauerte die
konferenz doch wieder länger als geplant
um mir die zeit zu vertreiben habe ich
jetzt auch dieses ständig was geholt
ein fan ist ja auch der bodo ramelow aus
thüringen der später sogar während der
konferenz an der er teilnimmt und hat
dafür ordentlich prügel bekommen hier
csu-spitzenpolitiker fordert rücktritt
von ramelow
na klar ich meine während der konferenz
aufs handy schauen macht man als gut
erzogener erwachsener natürlich nich
oder während sitzungen gibt sich hin und
wieder die gelegenheit die gedanken
eigentlich ganz nett man weiß ja was
gesagt wird
ups gemerkt so bartl merkel
aber unter uns wer während einer
konferenz in langweiligen vortrag oder
in der schule noch nie am handy gedreht
hat oder mal nachrichten geschaut hat
der werfe den ersten stein
übrigens werden wir dieser konferenz
nicht nur ein paar digitale drops mit
dem handy gelöscht sondern manchmal auch
recht vertrauliche infos verschickt
[Musik]
wer von euch alle meldungen auf sein
handy bekommt der weiß vielleicht wovon
ich rede an den tagen dieser konferenzen
wird man ganz kirre journalisten
ehrlicherweise auch ständig vibriert
ständig gibt es neue meldungen alle
warten auf die erlösende nachricht seit
tagen werden die verhandlungen mal
wieder quasi öffentlich geführt
eilmeldungen als live-ticker muss man
eigentlich vertraulichen runde
es gibt kein gremium in der deutschen
politik aus dem meer durch gestochen
wird so heißt das hier in berlin wenn
infos oder papiere herausgegeben werden
die wie das tun wollen entweder und
journalisten anfüttern sich profilieren
oder die öffentliche debatte in ihrem
sinne beeinflussen
trotzdem fragt man sich ja reden die
nicht eigentlich vertraulich miteinander
naja eigentlich schon aber wegen corona
treffen die sich eben per video seite
und dann sitzen da nicht nur die 16 mps
und merkel
jeder hat vertrauensleute neben sich
sitzen die mit höheren aber nicht von
den anderen gesehen werden den chef der
staatskanzlei die pressesprecherin
und irgendeiner von denen sticht immer
was durch am anfang vor einem jahr das
noch für mächtig ärger gesorgt vor allem
bei merkel
und mittlerweile sind auch
spitzenpolitiker ratlos ich habe beim
letzten mal nur mich eingeführt indem
ich gesagt habe
bitte alle meine zitate mit meinem
regierungssprecher und telefonnummer
sowie so entsprechend abstimmen wirklich
das ist es ja so ist es und das ist eine
politische kultur die nicht gutes da
hält sich natürlich keiner dran was
haseloff meint satzfetzen werden
herausgegeben der zusammenhang fehlt und
das misstrauen steigt unter dem strich
führt es dazu dass die leute verwirrt
sind und dass sie den glauben in die
politik oder den glauben an den staat
verlieren
der mann war selber mal journalist und
auch regierungssprecher und ich finde er
hat einen punkt was also tun
handy verbot wäre eine idee tatsächlich
hatte die runde mal persönlich traf im
letzten sommer 16 und merkel in einem
raum da gab es über stunden auf einmal
keine nachrichten
nur sich ständig während corona
persönlich zu treffen ist vielleicht
nicht so dass gute signal also verlagert
man die wichtigen debatten jetzt aus der
sitzung heraus oder versucht es
zumindest trifft sich vorher in
sogenannten a und b runden das sind die
von der spd geführten regierungen und b
die von der union
das ist zumindest ein kleines bisschen
vertrauliche und noch wichtiger noch
vertraulicher eine kleine fehler runde
die vorher das wichtige abstimmen soll
mit den beiden aktuellen vorsitzenden
der ministerpräsidentenkonferenz michael
müller aus berlin und markus söder aus
bayern und nagel und scholz von der
bundesregierung nur als da neulich auch
infos heraus sicherten obwohl doch
eigentlich nur diese vier und ihre
unterhändler informiert waren
da war man höre ich hinter den kulissen
echt verärgert irgendeiner wird offenbar
immer reden es wird sich also vermutlich
nichts ändern
die runde bleibt geschwätzig und wir
werden berichten interessiert ja auch
alle ist vielleicht auch nicht das
größte problem noch größer
möglicherweise dass sich da immer 17
parteien einigen müssen
[Musik]
16 länder und eine bundeskanzlerin der
das lange gezerre auch ziemlich auf die
nerven geht
so haben wir dann mit ihnen intensiver
diskussion doch wieder einige stunden
miteinander verbracht intensiv das nur
mal als erklärung ist in der politik
eine nette umschreibung für wir haben
uns richtig gezockt eigentlich aber ist
in der runde jedem klar was die menschen
in deutschland erwarten ich weiß dass
der wunsch nach bundeseinheitlichen
regeln
da ist aber da treffen 16
landesregierungen aufeinander 13
verschiedene koalitionen politiker die
am liebsten das land lahmlegen würden
bis es keine corona fälle mehr gibt und
solche die sagen das geht nicht
und daneben eine kanzlerin die immer
wieder ernüchtert feststellen muss in
entscheidenden fragen hat sie kaum was
zu sagen dann muss ich einfach auch als
bundeskanzlerin akzeptieren dass unsere
föderale ordnung es so ist dass die
kultusfreiheit einfach in den genen
liegt und so passiert an sobald wir
haben 22 januar
merkel hält in berlin ihre
pressekonferenz und verkündet danach
lehnen sie schon grundsätzlich
geschlossen und fast zeitgleich tritt in
stuttgart winfried kretschmann auf und
sagt grundsätzlich stimme das ja aber
bei ihnen würden die schulen und kitas
jetzt geöffnet hat er nachher doch nicht
gemacht
wegen der mutation es ist ein muster
dieser runde
mal öffnet hinter sachsen als erstes die
blumenläden dann sachsen als erstes die
schulen was wiederum ein mann aus bayern
ziemlich ärgert sie
immer schade wenn wir uns in berlin auch
nach anhörung durch die wissenschaft auf
ein klares verfahren verständigen und
wir dann zwei tage später komplett
unterschiedliche maßnahmen haben echt
schade oder einfach nur unprofessionell
wir haben halt 16 fürsten und fürsten
die sich profilieren wollen
für den wahlkampf die nächst höhere
aufgabe und die meinen sie könnten die
lage vor ort halt besser einschätzen und
fans schief geht kann man sich nachher
immer noch entschuldigen ich musste das
einfach sagen ich weiß auch habe es noch
genau im ohr dass die bundeskanzlerin
eindringlich gesagt hat es werden zahlen
auf uns zukommen da werden wir noch sehr
sehr sehr sehr uns daran erinnern und
wünschen dass wir sie wieder hätten
und ich muss sagen sie hat recht gehabt
und ich habe unrecht gehabt also wenn
die alle so viel quatschen und nachher
jeder macht was er will ist das
überhaupt die richtige runde
[Musik]
könnte sollte man das nicht anders
organisieren uns dass wir alle vier
wochen auf diese blaue wand im
kanzleramt starren und auf erlösung
hoffen müssen da gibt es welche wie
neulich der schriftsteller thomas
brussig in der sz die fordern mehr
diktatur wagen steile these corona
diktatur brussig sagt das system mit den
16 ministerpräsidenten und
ministerpräsidenten ist einfach zu
schwerfällig die wissenschaft müsse
diktieren die politik einfach nur
umsetzen und wenn das virus dann gebannt
sei dann so brussig könnten wir zur
geliebten normalität zurückkehren
ehrlich gesagt das finde ich ziemlich
großen nicht ich bin froh in einer
demokratie zu leben wo öffentlich
diskutiert wird und wo von uns gewählten
volksvertreterinnen und volksvertreter
entscheiden auch wenn es mal ein paar
tage dauert zum thema diktatur empfehle
ich euch übrigens das video meines
kollegen thomas reichert die hat sich
mit der frage beschäftigt ob diktaturen
das mit corona besser in den griff
kriegen link gibt's hier oben in der
politischen debatte hier geht es ja eher
darum mehr demokratie zu wagen den
bundestag zu beteiligen und zwar bevor
sich diese kleine runde trifft dafür
muss die debatte aber vor der
entscheidung stattfinden und der ort der
entscheidung muss das parlament sein
ich finde er hatte einen punkt aber
gleichzeitig stimmt eben auch wir leben
in einem föderalen system also einen
bundesstaat mit 16 bundesländern und
geteilten kompetenzen und aktuell ist
der infektionsschutz in deutschland eben
ländersache
um das zu ändern müsste man den bund
deutlich mehr macht geben ob das mitten
in einer krise passiert habe ich den
chef der unionsfraktion gesagt es ist
unsere förderrate verfassung so wie wir
sie haben so wie sie im grundgesetz
angelegt worden ist aber nach der
pandemie
da müssen wir uns zusammensetzen und
müssen was wirklich fragen ob diese
föderale weg in so großen krisen wie
jetzt die fahne wie eine ist der
richtige weg ist das entscheidende wort
habt ihr gehört oder nach der pandemie
mittendrin hat man erstmal wichtigere
aufgaben und ob die länder dem zustimmen
würden ist eher zweifelhaft
also wenn ihr mich jetzt fragt ich finde
es wäre schon viel gewonnen wenn erstens
die merkel sich mal vor einer mpk der
debatte im bundestag stellen würde wenn
zweiter
diese mpk auch mal einen längerfristigen
plan vorlegen will
wenn drittens ich weiß das klingt total
verrückt sich mal alle an das halten was
sie auch beschlossen haben aber wie seht
ihr das
schreibt es mir in die kommentare ich
freue mich auf eine sachliche diskussion
und wenn es euch gefallen hat lasten
like da oder schreibt welche anderen
themen euch mal für einen blick hinter
die kulissen in berlin interessieren
würden davor lohnen sich auch die
anderen folgen von inside politics zum
beispiel zur frage ob geimpfte
eigentlich mehr rechte bekommen sollen
als andere auch eine spannende debatte
viel spaß